we will never wake up to certain  realities until we are physically in  pain I think it was Yuri besman of that  said you will not know that you are  being manipulated you will not know that  Society is being demoralized you will  not know that you are literally living  under tyranny until you're on your way  to the gas Chambers that's the only way  you will know and I think the same thing  is true for covid and the vaccines you  took that thing without even thinking  about it but you won't know until like  maybe you can't get pregnant maybe you  can't have children maybe you have  health issues maybe as a man you now  have a heart problem show